well creativity is in the
non-linearities
right but productivity is in the
implementation of linearities i mean
that's that's what
is absolutely clear this is why i think
we were talking earlier about why a
formal rigorous training in something
where other people are looking at you
and telling you no not good enough go
back and do it again
there's real value to that because
otherwise it's just ideas it's just
vapors
you know one the thing that matt
mentioned as the study that they're
working on
is as opposed to i think most of the
psychedelic studies
they've done is on how to treat
different conditions
and one of the things they're working on
now is to try to do a study where
uh for creatives for people that don't
have a
condition to try and treat but instead
see how
this how psychedelics can help you
create
so like goodness if you take creatives
and you give them more psychedelics
they're not going to be able to get out
of their room
i don't know well but this is the i
maybe you can speak to that
psychedelics or not or dreams or tools
in general how to be better creatives
that's an interesting i don't often see
studies of this nature of like
how to take high performance in the
mental
creative space and get them to perform
even
uh better so it's not average people
it's like
masters of their craft like taking i
mean his examples was taking an elon
musk which is in the engineering space
and maybe musicians and all that kind of
stuff
and studying that that's a i mean that's
weird
i usually the science uh the scientific
exploration there has been done in uh by
the musicians themselves as has been
documented like jazz is like
all non-linearities yeah right but if
it's
but the people still have to know how to
play their instruments right right
there's some early
early skill building that's critical i
mean
when you mention someone like elon i
mean virtual i mean he's already a
virtuoso right because he and in so many
different domains
i've never met him but it's it's clear
right he
it's not just that he's ambitious and
bold and brave and all that it's all
that
and there's there's clearly
a different way of looking at the same
problems that everyone else is looking
at
and people are probably banging their
head against the refrigerator thinking
like think differently things
it doesn't work that way it involved
there's a certain anxiety in
for the i'm not talking about for elon
but i don't have no idea
but i think for somebody who's very
structured very regimented very linear
the anxiety comes from letting go of
those linearities
and for the person that's very creative
the anxiety comes from
trying to impose linearities right the
really creative artist or musician
they're they seem
nuts they seem like they can't get their
life together because they can't
and they you know we look at people who
are kind of pseudo-aspergers or
aspergers or some forms of autism and
they are
so hyper-linear but you take away those
linearities and they freak out
and that's kind of the essence of some
of those syndromes so i think that
the ability to toggle back and forth
between those states is what's
remarkable i mean
because we're here and we're having this
discussion i mean steve jobs is a good
example he
probably the best example of somebody
who actually talked about his own
process
about the merging of art and science
arts and engineering
humanities and science very few people
can do that
well i you seem to have a capacity to do
that i i'd like you you
know poetry and you are ai guy like you
there's nothing linear about poetry as
far as i can tell
you